April and May are the hottest months of
the year in valise it's a time when many
farmers set fire to their land a
tradition that dates back to ancient
times
it destroys biodiversity destroy the
soil it can destroy crops it can destroy
communities it just so destructive it's
not the best way to or arm practice
agriculture known as slash and burn the
fires actually make the earth fertile
for a short time because plant remains
fall to the ground and mix with the
otherwise barren soil but the fires also
release huge amounts of carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere
we've come to Toledo in the south of
Belize the district is home to the
indigenous kitschy Maya who traced their
roots back to the ancient Maya they've
kept many of their forefathers
traditions including slash-and-burn
agriculture in the past it was more
sustainable because farmers only
cultivated enough land to feed their
families my ancestors
knew what it was to protect nature they
knew that they were one with nature but
as commercialization of food comes into
the picture we start making money of
food so we sacrifice all of those things
like nature and and unsustainability to
make money
Gustavo reckoner works for the nonprofit
organization Jacque Jay the NGO is
working with local farmers to introduce
methods that are more sustainable for
our modern times another problem with
the fires is that they often get out of
control like this one which are spread
to a neighboring field
our goal would not be to eliminate fires
completely because it is a part of the
culture
and a part of a tradition what we would
want is to put in place the best
practices to ensure that we protect
biodiversity and other forms because
escape fires do also threaten our farms
because when a fire escape so you have
no control over it
you can damage communities and people's
lives so alternative options are needed
Gustavo a cane and his NGO are pursuing
a number of different strategies
including cocoa farming in a protected
forest area which Jacques Jai has the
right to use smallholder farmers are
being taught how to grow organic cocoa
that gives them an income without having
to damage the forest because the cocoa
plants actually need the shade of the
other trees
in order to grow properly
[Music]
for example of zero use of pesticides
chemicals you know the use of fire is
you know it is controlled in another
part of the forest outside the protected
reserve there are plans to start growing
corn and beans instead of slash-and-burn
agriculture inga trees are making the
ground here fertile
farmer orlando kekulé planted them three
years ago the tops of the trees now form
a canopy overhead and the leaves and
seeds that have fallen to the ground
have created a nitrogen rich soil as
fertile as after a fire you can't even
find the mulch the blocks are no see as
a lot of mulch we had restore back to
this soil it's more fertile you can see
with help from Jacques Jai he plans to
sell the first maize seeds in a few
weeks but first he'll cut off the tops
of the trees to allow more light for the
plants the trees will grow back again
later when he used to slash and burn the
land would lie waste for years after the
now wildlife is starting to return first
I don't even see any anymore birds
around and even rabbits and even there
there was a visitor idea there was a
deer here and I'm happy they are like
coming back closer because if I was
doing to going to do burning I'll do
smoke or day the fire gonna chase so
much and if the animals are afraid of
fire so they could have got the wrong
Gustavo recognizes helping to convince
more farmers of the benefits of these
sustainable farming methods
he says it's obvious that things need to
change here another piece of forest has
just been burned to the ground
of course I do feel a sudden when I look
at it but I also feel proud because it
shows that if I don't do it and if my
organization don't doesn't do it if my
colleagues don't do it then who is going
to do it so it gives me a sense of pride
to know that we are doing the right
thing
you